beautiful morning outside i guess it's
not going to stay that way though huh
well
it depends on what your uh definition of
beauty is john
i have many i've made
not everybody loves thunderstorms so
though i i kind of like a little
lightning
lightning at night is gorgeous we
haven't had any nighttime thunderstorms
in a long time
and i don't think that we're going to
have those those are usually a
feature of summertime you know but we're
looking at the slight chance of some
thunderstorms this afternoon along with
some rain this morning
we've got some southwest breezes some
more clouds coming in and look at that
beautiful sun hiding behind the clouds
this morning
lots of 40s around the valley this
morning and some neighborhoods still
getting those bumpy southwest breezes
so where you've got those winds 15 20
miles an hour it's feeling like the 30s
out there so nice warm jackets coats
and maybe grab an umbrella for the
afternoon because that's really when
we're expecting
the better chance for some showers 40s
in mesquite look at cali any in the 20s
and we are looking at some snow in our
mountains look at ely at nine
reno's getting snow right now at 29
degrees
so we'll be cooler today too with highs
only in the 50s
not only today but tomorrow and friday
and friday morning we're still thinking
there might be a slight chance of a
little
snow mixed with some rain out on the
west side early in the morning
we'll see still in the forecast and then
by the weekend we're back to sunshine we
spring forward into daylight saving time
start getting a little uh cat nap in
here to make up for losing that hour of
sleep
that we'll lose when we spring forward
set our clocks ahead this weekend
we are looking a lot of rain and snow
that's kind of spreading out
fanning out across california there's
been some heavy rain in some areas
excuse me the central valley lots of
snow in the sierras
with winter storm warnings they could
see a couple of feet of snow
by the end of the week by the time the
system gets through it's going to be a
slow
roller you can see some areas of heavy
rain down around southern california
and we're watching the radar just been
some very very light returns
up in our local mountains as the clouds
get heavier and thicker
and the atmosphere gets a little juicier
we'll see that better chance of showers
into the afternoon and early evening 57
that's it for the high today
and mid 50s tomorrow 57 on friday chance
of scattered showers probably after the
morning drive again tomorrow
and then after a friday we're back to
good sunshine for the weekend
and even mostly sunny skies next week
with mid to upper 60's